alors pourquoi ne pas faire une intro
norbert vous expliquant ce qui va se
passer dans cette vidéo nous sommes sur
blocs ou de blog foot qu'est ce que
c'est un jeune en qui l'on va créer
notre propre écosystème c'est à dire
qu'on va créer un espace d'ailleurs
assez verticale parce que la surface au
sol limitée un espace qui va s'auto
suffire c'est à dire qu'on produira tout
ce qu'il faut pour que les gens soient
bien que ce soit des trucs physique ou
du doute pas physique je propose tout
simplement de lancer une partie en bac à
sable en mode eco logis je vais vous
expliquer c'est ouf c'est ouf j'adore
j'adore ce jeu donc on commence on est
là il ya quatre types de constructions
illégales les espaces publics qui vont
créer du coup une communauté qui vont
créer de 2,2 interactions entre les gens
il ya les espaces de production qui vous
permet de produire tout ce qui est
lectrice it et aux engrais ci a besoin
d'engrais tout ça via les bâtiments qui
vont permettre que bas des gens en
ménage ici tout simplement ici des gens
ménages sacré quoi ça crée du travail
sacrés de la consommation voilà tout ça
est ici ce sont les blocs organique
c'est-à-dire les blocs qui vont créer du
bien-être pour les habitants en cliquant
ici panneaux des ressources on voit
l'état des ressources de son oud son oud
cerveau sabine actuellement par exemple
on a 150 $ et on a 1000 points d'eau
souterraine on ne consomme pas on ne
perd pas mais on ne gagne pas non plus
on est à 0 je vous propose de commencer
par mettre en place un sol hop hop hop
hop voilà comme vous pouvez le voir ici
les indicateurs nous montrent qu'on est
en train de gagner en eau souterraine
voilà c'est juste un truc qui produit de
l'eau souterraine et c'est très bien
comme ça pour vivre et nos faux quoi il
nous faut de l'électricité mais
l'électricité par exemple dans les
centrales pour la faire il faut de
l'uranium
ça ça ne va pas nous ce qu'on veut c'est
l'électricité sans qu'ils aient besoin
de rien pour la produire
le panneau solaire et oui vous le
connaissez tous va se faire manger de
panneaux solaires ici hop hop hop voilà
panneaux solaires ça va nous créer un
maximum d'électricité dans votre corps
il ya quoi majoritairement de l'eau
l'eau c'est la vie et cette imitation de
jeune rachid qui imite van damme est nul
ça c'est par la ville on va donc
construire des châteaux d'eau qui vont
produire de l'eau ces châteaux d'eau par
contre vont nous coûter régulièrement de
l'argent deux dollars par mois 5
châteaux d'eau égale ton abonnement
netflix est terrible on va quand même en
mettre 3
c'est la famille donc là comme vous
pouvez le voir notre indicateur est vert
partout sauf en argent bien sûr parce
qu'on paye pour ces châteaux d'eau et on
a rien qui rapportent de l'argent
du coup je me pose que des gens viennent
habiter l'armée pour que les gens
viennent habiter il nous faut de l'air
frais et des belles choses et leurs
frais et ses belles choses ce sont les
palmiers que nous les donne qui n'a
jamais rêvé d'avoir des palmiers voilà
maintenant qui est un peu d'air frais et
une belle vue sur les palmiers qu'à
autre chose que cette [ __ ] de panneaux
solaires en gros on va pouvoir commencer
à mettre des appartements et des gens
vont venir
habiter ici et bien évidemment avec ceci
pour générer de l'argent ou tâche est ta
bouteille de vodka samedi soir comme
intermarché est fermé à l'épicerie du
coin et là on va commencer à faire de
l'argent des abonnés et là ça nous fait
plaisir trois appartements ici deux
épiceries
franchement on est bien on est archi
bien maintenant s'il va falloir mettre
ces des passages pour que les gens
puissent atteint les épiceries et c'est
donc on ne peut pas y accéder jusqu'aux
mamba là mais c'est pour ça qu'on fait
faillite les mecs n'accèdent pas aux
épiceries mais pourquoi il ya un chemin
là moi je fais de la merde
[Musique]
pardon en fait c'est le sol de merde là
que j'ai mis là qui créent des de l'eau
souterraine en fait faut que je le met
juste que tu es quoi faire une tour de
sol voilà comme ça on n'en parle plus
voilà c'est très moche m'en bats les
couilles je reprends l'électricité le
grand air
l'eau les habitants les épiceries
talât la ville et enfin bref j'ai un peu
galéré parce qu'en gros il faut bien
doser entre combien de ressources y'a
bon pour combien d'habitants et combien
d'habitants pour combien d'épicerie
avant la psi a trop de commerces passé
d'habitants les gens achètent pas
consomment pas les pis si elles ferment
comme vous voulez voir on est dans le
rouge en eau souterraine merci la tour
d'eau souterraine
c'est bien un truc que j'ai fait de ma
vie c'est tout simplement honteux en
consommateurs on en a toujours pas assez
de ce que je propose c'est de faire des
maisons avec étage on peut tout
simplement ajouter un appartement ici et
aussi ici et en fait on va juste
construire un ascenseur pour qu'ils
puissent accéder à leur appartement mais
l'ascenseur là et on normes et un au
dessus
sauf que là il va falloir commencer à
faire un étage tac tac tac tac tout ça
va bien évidemment tenir
qu'est-ce qui prend de la thune là je
comprends pas c'est juste ça c'est juste
un truc là qu'ils prennent autant dessus
des châteaux d'eau sigean dégageait
attention on a on va peut-être vu la
première immense sécheresse de france et
bah non c'est bon et là du coup on gagne
presque à ses tunes et pourquoi n'a pas
certain du tout dans le négatif c'est
insupportable voyons en haut on va faire
un bas au monde yeux tout ce que ça
donne comme tu dois faire un bar faudra
bien pour faire de la bière ok j'ai
compris il faut du blé champs de blé
papa on en met deux incroyables la
brasserie qui va se mettre à crédin bien
avant faire deux ont fait péter le bar
bon mari bon le problème c'est que tout
est dégueulasse là commencera ménages
cette merde faut faire un deuxième étage
un désolé le prennent attache c'était là
la bêta était l'alpha test désolé les
gars super on fait une deuxième
brasserie je peux pas maître de chant là
dessus pourquoi
mais non je peux veille de leurs moteurs
sont interdits on n'a pas le choix d'un
de leurs moteurs agco peuvent l'être en
haut de la tour d'eau souterraine génial
attends je suis et ce que je peux 40 le
jour dans sa un peu ben voilà où sera
notre exploitation de bière elle
descendra en même temps que l'eau
souterraine on aura des nappes
phréatiques de bière mon pote le
deuxième bar on manque de consommateurs
et le manque de vent frais [ __ ] jeter
des chéneaux là où c'est vraiment le
dépôt voilà le vent frais c'est réglé
maintenant ce qu'il nous faut c'est plus
d'appart un plat ou plat un plat mais du
consommateur mon pote mec je crois que
je viens d'avoir une idée exceptionnel
on recommence à zéro
regardez bien première étape on fait un
étage complet de sol comme ça on aura
jamais de problème d'eau de mer 20
hockey l avantage sur le souci qu'on
peut construire ce qu'on veut parce que
c'est du sol je repars à zéro parce que
c'est important je pense d'eux déjà
produire tout ce qu'il faut avant de se
mettre à ramener des gens et tout ce nom
après c'est la merde tu construis
mutation de construire un arbre n'a plus
aucun sens on a nos appart la sas et
ressources pour le moment tout est
suffisant sauf l'argent parce qu'il va
falloir commencer à ouvrir des épiceries
pourquoi ça ne crée pas de consommateurs
mais merde je les empêche de sortir de
leurs maisons à cause des des eaux le
corps pardon vous avoir enfermé désolé
désolé désolé c'est terrible ce que j'ai
fait terrible les amis j'ai dû modifier
ici j'ai dû retirer un étage du sol pour
mettre des appartements les gens y ont
accès via l'ascenseur qui par-delà pour
aller à les tâches c'est très très bien
ce qu'on a fait on génère pas de thunes
mais séparables parce qu'on va faire le
premier bar de l'endroit soit faire
c'est très simple quatre champs de blé
et bien sûr de la bras ce riz une fois
que ceux-ci aient fait la nation m un
bar qui va générer des millions d'euros
à ba incroyable dont clairement c'est
maintenant que tout va jouer et voir si
ce que je veux faire ça marche ou pas ce
que ça marche laitages et créer
[ __ ] mais c'est génial ici on a la
liste des habitants et on peut voir ce
qu'ils aiment ballet est un client
qu'est ce qu'ils aiment balle et ils
aiment les donner et il aime les médias
il écoute brousse il aime les fruits et
il aime les légumes
bruce tu as un gars bien marché il faut
des légumes et du poisson ferme de
légumes je crois que c'est exactement ce
qu'ont cherché je viens de créé ma
petite soeur de l'aquatic qui va le
faire mon poisson je fais maintenant ma
petite ferme hydroponique il va me faire
mes légumes on n'a plus qu'à faire le
marché
tiens je suis trop content j'ai réussi à
vraiment a créé ma petite ville ici là
même si cet appart avec vue sur le sol
est un peu ghetto j'ai des thunes
on va gagner en électricité pour quoi
faire de grandes choses on va mettre
deux générateurs mon pote
mfg en train de construire un empire
c'est un truc de ouf franchement on est
trop bien je sais j'ai trop excité je
sais plus quoi faire j'ai plongé plus
quoi faire tout va trop bien on va
ouvrir la ville aux touristes mon gars
bien sûr hôtel formule 1 il faut de
l'eau chaude et des touristes
ok on va résoudre ce problème tout de
suite chauffe eau solaire n'est pas un
chauffe-eau genre qui bombarde plus tu
es bon alors être le chauffe eau solaire
un peu nul
est-ce qu'on peut le mettre là mais oui
par dessus les générateurs c'est
incroyable ce qu'on est en train de
faire le show faut c'est fait les taux y
seront bien et bon ça chauffe et les
pieds encore faut-il qu'il y ait des
touristes comme ange attire des
touristes ici à un néon publicitaire
voilà ce qui attire ces [ __ ] de
touristes il ya un doute qui peut
attirer des touristes un truc mieux
qu'un opus terre dégueulasse il se bat à
assise un obélisque mais bien sûr c'est
évident obélisque est-ce que du coup les
touristes arrivent il est l'heure
d'ouvrir le premier hôtel de las quizy
city pas là
c'est tout et c'est quoi cet hôtel monga
l'hôtel on dirait une machine à laver ni
calme et bien voilà les années 70 cette
vidéo sur l'egée pas oublié le nom je
suis pas du tout en train de faire un
retour hinault ces blacks blackwood il
s'appelle gta chez vous a plu ces gars
n'hésitez pas à aller mais comme
d'habitude
et puis [ __ ] c'était un jeu mais qu
est hyper cool le principe est génial et
ses complexes quoi enfin je veux dire
les mecs qui n'ont pas fait le jeu ils
ont pas fait les choses à moitié ils ont
vraiment poussé le truc à fond alors
j'ai commencé à enregistrer la vidéo
pour la petite histoire est au bout de
dix minutes j'ai fait dans ma tête je
comprends à ça pas du tout faut que je
fasse le tuto juger un cerveau trop nuls
et les review steam disait ça qu au
début tu te fait un peu chier tu
comprends pas trop aidé et que tu
commences à bien en boite et tout s'est
vraiment bien voilà si vous n'avez pas
quitté la vidéo sous ses explications
relou je vous remercie en vous chantant
ce travail côté papa rod
[Musique]
ça